[Música]
e
[Aplausos]
[Música]
sí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
pérez
quieres
i
[Música]
yo andaba con rafelito y caco el ocre o
en plena carretera comiendo no un
chinche
[Música]
al frente de nosotros había un bebé
que parecía
un propulsor de motorista extremo que
iban a más de 100
van para adelante el tramo
no estabas plantado
y había una señora
[Música]
echando agua a lo humano
y sus pinturas
empolvado
como si iban a una boda
viví
en san rafael la brisa eterna caliente
qué pasa
de la carretera al conde
sí
y
[Música]
no
la escultura
vegetales que adornan
la piedra o vertical
en españa
acariciaba por nubes
que como al calvario van a la ciudad
[Música]
como el calvario a la ciudad a trabajar
como un calvario me siento yo
[Música]
con un calvario monótono
qué aventura
[Música]
para mí
la delincuencia y su atadura
estoy la policía
julio con 1 tono
calvario
vámonos
a la ayuda a trabajar
[Aplausos]
a la ciudad
las nubes
y van llorando
[Música]
gracias
ay las nubes
el mar
y
antes
bailar
llorando
[Música]
por no tono
e
[Música]
aguantar la misma [ __ ]
en la ciudad
y
sí
[Música]
buenas tardes
yo soy richter h yo que dedico lópez
esta canción que acaban de escuchar
trata de un recorrido por la zona sur de
quisqueya en este país esa isla hermosa
que tenemos un paisaje de elementos que
se forman en san rafael donde va el río
se junta con la playa y las piedras del
río y el agua de la playa comienzan a
hacer una simbiosis con el feeling de
todo el mundo así como en cada universo
lleno de sabores de colores y de olores
así en la música y así en el día a día
traemos eso para ustedes esta canción
nació de forma muy natural
así mismo hay muchas formas de crear
música no me refiero a que va primero si
la letra la armonía o la melodía me
refiero a que siempre se comienza con
una idea y se retroalimenta y aquí vamos
a jugar con algunos conceptos con los
que nos encanta experimentar y ahora
vamos en camino a la ciudad recordando
ese fin de semana donde jugamos las olas
del mar con el río mientras el esplendor
del sol reflejaba en el horizonte pura
alegría pero para nuestro día como
transmito dicho sentimiento en un
fragmento musical comenzaré ahora por él
el feeling que quiero que transmita la
siguiente música de improvisación y
quiero comunicar alegría y felicidad y
optimismo vamos a elaborar esa idea con
ese feeling o ese sentimiento así que
necesito de richi un verso con mucho
power
de lo que admite y suelta lo que no te
apoya es la vida es muy corta para vivir
esa condena y no te mortifiques deja que
todo critique que no creo que en su vida
aplique como lo que a ti te exige vive
lo que a ti te llena
[Aplausos]
vive lo que a ti te llena
[Música]
dime lo que a ti me llena vive lo que a
ti te llena y vive lo que a ti te
llenaba
[Música]
[Aplausos]
vives lo que a ti te llena
o sea vive lo que a ti te llena la
música sin letra
[Música]
pero cuando vamos funciona en unidad el
mensaje son más fuerte en lo que andy se
llena
[Música]
vive lo que a ti te llena
digamos que ya llegue el lunes y
comienza la semana las cosas se ponen
más pesadas más difíciles pasa
brillantes
así que vamos a agregarle atención a la
música a esa idea rítmica ollin yoliztli
para girar la moneda así comunicar algo
triste para mí de eso se trata la
producción musical de alimentar una idea
haciéndola más fuerte impactante así que
ahora necesito un verso más emotivo
[Aplausos]
a veces uno no mira lo detalle de la
vida la pureza del momento cada paz no
cada cuento
a veces uno no escucha lo que de tu
interior en managua y viviendo la semana
pasando la misma lucha
vive en lo que a ti te llena y vive lo
que a ti te llega
[Música]
[Aplausos]
vive lo que a ti me llena y de los
indígenas
volvemos el primer sentimiento
[Música]
[Aplausos]
vive lo que active
vívelo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
vive lo que haces
[Música]
ah
vive lo que a ti te llegaba
e
[Música]
dime lo que a ti te llena
[Aplausos]
y
del duelo que a mí me leña
[Música]
vive
escribe lo que a ti te llena
[Música]
eso
vive lo que a ti te llena vívelo vívelo
en lo que a ti te llena
[Música]
no creo que ustedes
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pero
en algo
verdad
aquí
vaya vaya
ah
y queremos que los días pasen se vuelve
muy manta
plateado el tiempo ahí
y por fin llega el tren de semanas
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el cantante y compositor editorial oye
la voz y la producción en los escritos y
la buena nota
[Música]
[Aplausos]
e
[Música]
[Aplausos]